let's continue our discussion of the desperation
from the Trump campaign.
The president is now so desperate that he's
holding three rallies per day in the middle
of a 100 year pandemic.
Yesterday, holding rallies in Allentown, Pennsylvania,
Lititz, Pennsylvania.
That sounds weird, but I guess I maybe it's
light.
It's I'm not.
I hope I'm not mispronouncing that.
And Martinsburg, Pennsylvania.
All three of them in Pennsylvania that I can
tell you with full pronunciation certainty.
I'm not going to go through all of these rallies
with you.
I'm going to go through some elements.
They are completely dystopian, authoritarian
nightmares, the likes of which we actually
have never seen before in American history.
We've seen stuff like this in other parts
of the world, particularly in the 20th century,
but we've not seen this type of stuff in America.
I'm going to go through just a few highlights
to give you an overall sense of how much of
an emergency it is to remove this man.
Starting in Allentown, Pennsylvania, yesterday
morning, Donald Trump, who has continued to
say foreign leaders want Biden to win because
Trump is so tough on them.
Now, Trump is just making up conversations,
claiming a foreign leader said Joe Biden would
sleep all the time if he were president.
Take a listen to this person elected.
They will delay the vaccine, delay therapies,
prolong the pandemic.
Close your schools.
Your schools have to open and shut down.
Our country doesn't have a clue.
Sky doesn't have a clue.
Have you seen what I mean?
We can't play with the country.
The only thing I can tell you for sure.
President Xi from China.
President Putin from Russia.
Kim Jong un.
North Korea.
And I could name 40 others.
Their sharpest attack.
They don't want to deal with Slippery Joe.
One of them said to me, one of the leaders
said, well, I hope you win because we don't
want to deal with somebody that sleeps all
the time.
You know, he just announced a leg.
Well, no.
You know, now now that you mention it, I don't
believe that that conversation happened.
I don't think it did.
This is really interesting.
Trump did the thing yesterday.
He used to do this back in 2016.
He pulled out a piece of paper out of his
jacket pocket where he reads polling numbers.
And Trump is trying to push back on polls
that show him losing the election.
But he's doing it by bragging about his leads
in places like Utah and West Virginia.
I'll tell you why this is interesting in a
moment.
In Montana, we're so far up that don't even
into shouldn't even have the election.
Likewise in Utah.
So far up where?
Plus twelve plus fifteen.
And in West Virginia, with 20 up 20 points.
Are just came out.
They came out today.
If you are a Republican incumbent president
and you're bragging about polling in Utah,
in West Virginia, you in trouble.
You are in trouble.
If in order to have good numbers, you are
even mentioning Utah and Virginia, two states
that because they are so red are irrelevant
to the Electoral College process.
In practice, they're not irrelevant.
They're irrelevant because their results are
not in question.
The election doesn't hinge on them.
And Trump is saying, I'm doing great in Utah.
I'm doing great in West Virginia.
Very troubling sign.
Trump continuing his complete rage against
wind power.
He seems to believe that if there's wind power,
if it's not windy out, you can't watch TV.
No air conditioning in the summer, no heat
during the winter and no electricity during
peak hours.
Let's watch President Trump on television.
I'm sorry.
We won't be able to do it.
The wind is blowing today, darling.
We will.
And part of the tragedy is that the crowd
seems to also think that's how wind power
works.
If it isn't windy, you can't watch TV.
If it's not windy, you can't toast your bread
in that moment.
Complete misunderstanding.
Deliberate ignorance.
We may never know.
Then Trump moving on from Allentown, Pennsylvania,
to Lititz, Pennsylvania.
Trump struggling to say extremist.
I guess this is extremist.
And Trump just struggling to speak by rally
number two.
I'm keeping the terrorist jihadists and violent
extremists, those terrible extremists the
hell out of our country.
That's OK.
Trump fans then starting a lock him up chant
towards Hunter Biden.
Lock up Hillary, lock up Joe Biden.
Lock up the Bidens, lock up.
Hunter Biden to state is supposed to ask us.
And they weren't going to, but we told them,
I'm sorry.
Where's Hunter?
Is he making.
He's he's trying to make a deal with a foreign
country to pay him 10 million.
Where's Hunter?
Remember the t shirt?
I was right.
Thank you very much for that.
This can only happen in Pennsylvania.
I was here for school.
The party claiming to be for the Constitution,
for law and order, for due process, regularly
demanding the imprisonment without due process
of random people who haven't even been accused
of crimes.
Law and order.
Right.
Constitutional conservatives Trump then going
back to the vaccine saying any set momentarily,
we're going to have it he money.
Maybe he'll even announce it at a rally today
ends a pandemic which is ending with or without.
And we have the vaccines.
They're going to be very nobody would have
them.
It would be years before Yatta.
What I did with FDA and FDA has been terrific.
But it was called a slightly speedier process.
OK.
And totally safe.
We will have the vaccine like momentarily
and we're all set to distribute it before
the end of the year, maybe substantially before.
But it's going good.
But we are going to get ourselves back to
normal life.
I said no where we were seven months ago.
So as we have heard from Trump many times,
we were expecting a vaccine approval early
October, mid-October, late October before
the election.
We were expecting people, according to Trump,
to start getting the vaccine before the election.
Not happening.
And by any reasonable sense from our actual
public health experts, if we are lucky, if
things go paida, I want to say luck.
But if things go perfectly, we hopefully will
have some people starting to get vaccinated
by the end of this year.
Then on from Lititz, Pennsylvania, to Martinsburg,
Pennsylvania, Trump criticizing Barack Obama
for having a small crowd today.
Obama didn't do any event today, which was
yesterday.
Doesn't matter.
It's all fiction here.
It's really something, right?
Did you see the crowd that President Obama
had today?
Nobody.
Nobody showed up.
I thought they'd have a little crowd.
Didn't quite have a crowd like this.
No, nobody showed up.
They said he's going to start campaigning.
And I said, no, Barack Hussein Obama.
I said no.
I said, is that good or bad?
Because, you know, he campaigned harder than
Hillary the last time.
How did that work out?
It didn't work.
And then while bashing Joe Biden, this is
funny.
Trump gets confused and says Biden is going
to give you the biggest tax cut in the history
of the country.
Just like I make maybe a moment of clarity
or just Trump confused about what he wants
to say.
The largest tax cut in her seat is the craziest
campaign.
Right.
So all my life, I watch politicians running.
They always say we are going to cut your taxes,
right?
We are going to cut your.
I've got a guy running now who's got a shot.
He goes, we will raise your taxes.
I said, What the hell?
I said, did he just say, yeah, he's going
to give you the biggest tax cut in the history
of our country?
Yeah, I got confused watching it live.
But Biden's plan.
I mean, the funny thing is Biden's plan actually
is a tax cut for the bottom 95 percent of
Americans and a tax hike for the top five
percent of income earners.
Unclear what Trump meant to say.
Is Trump confused that he accidentally told
the truth?
You never know with this guy.
And then Donald Trump, again, incoherent on
Mexico, paying for the wall, which they did
but don't have to do because it's Bill.
But they paid for it.
Who knows what the hell he's talking about.
And Mexico is paying for the war, by the way.
Any question?
That's the other thing.
So now they know it's Bill.
Then they said Mexico will not be paying for.
I said, don't know.
Mexico is paying for the war.
OK, but they'll figure that out very soon.
They'll confiscate again a total lie.
The truth is there is no wall.
I think they've added about 10 miles as part
of a wall repair program.
There is no wall.
Trump promised the wall across the entire
border by the end of his first term.
There's no wall there.
And Mexico is paid for nothing.
There's no toll on people coming into the
United States from.
None of it is true.
And then just as a sort of mildly xenophobic
icing on the cake, Trump now regularly at
rallies, referring to the former president
as Barack Hussein Obama.
This is a common trope.
Hussein, Hussein, Hussein.
Hussein sounds like an a rab right.
This is the idea of Trump repeating it.
And part of that was that Barack Hussein Obama
allowed me to have one hundred and forty.
That's become a new staple of these rallies
in the last couple of weeks, authoritarian
nightmare.
Three more rallies today.
We may cover some of them live.
Barack Obama will also be rallying for Joe
Biden this week.
And I plan to cover those.
And we will have more coverage of this authoritarian
nightmare on the show's Instagram page.
If you are on Instagram, follow the show at
David Pakman show and follow me at David Pakman.